for one of the biggest games in Ubisoft
history far cry 5 and he's here right
now to unveil the next chapter please
welcome John Sebastian de Conte
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone as you may remember [ __ ]
high five indeed with nukes dropping on
Montana and this marked the very
beginning of a brand new world because
yes we're finally bringing the post
apocalypse to [ __ ] high and as the
creative director of this new project it
is my absolute pleasure to reveal to you
[ __ ] hi new dawn
[Applause]
we were just kids when the bombs dropped
and the world went to [ __ ] they said it
was supposed to be the end of everything
but for us it was just the beginning
[Applause]
surviving nah we were better than that
this new world had a lot to give and we
took it all that's how he came out on
top that's how we got here
that's how we found you
[Music]
you need to understand something the
only currency left in this world is
power we're gonna take everything from
you started with your home and if we
can't take you
we'll break
[Music]
[Music]
I led us into the new world I thought
that it would be glorious I was wrong
far